wir gehen live vor ort zu dem mann der
in der pressekonferenz dabei gewesen ist
peter tiede unser reporter dort vor ort
und er war derjenige der als erster die
frage nach den zwistigkeiten zwischen
dem expertenrat und karl lauterbach und
lothar wieler gestellt hat mehrfach
wurde dann noch mal nachgefragt kein mal
gab es eine richtige antwort darauf
peter
das ist aber auch ein zeichen also sowie
gefeiert wurde heißt das es ist ein
wirklich wirklich mann ist sauer auf
lothar wieler ich habe noch mit anderen
leuten gesprochen die sich im umfeld von
karl lauterbach aber auch bei anderen
auskennen und die gesagt haben das hat
gestern richtig gerappelt im karton der
minister war stocksauer und er musste
sich selbst dann dazu durchringen von
der freiheit der wissenschaft zu reden
und herrn wieder zuzugestehen dass er
als leiter einer behörde und als
professor natürlich frei darin ist
papiere und empfehlungen zu
veröffentlichen bei ihm werde es keine
zensur geben aber klar dahinter gestellt
klar er hat gesagt wenn ich nicht zu ihm
stehen würde dann sehr sehr er nicht
hier aber ist da sind richtig heftige
gewitter wolken mann ist stocksauer und
wenn der kanzler gestern in der runde
mit dem ministerpräsidenten den
ergo-chef abkanzelt wenn der
gesundheitsminister sich gestern in
dieser schaltkonferenz wirklich
verärgert zeigt dann zeigt es dass da
der haussegen wirklich schief hängt und
das lokal wieder hier wirklich einmal
übers ziel hinaus geschossen ist wir
konnten jetzt auch beobachten peter in
der pressekonferenz dass auch lothar
wieler als zunehmend genervt auf weitere
nachfragen der kolleginnen und kollegen
reagiert heißt wie schätzt du die
stimmung zwischen dem rk ii und der
politik jetzt für die nächsten wochen
ein
also es gibt schon dass es gibt schon
länger verwerfung die gab es auch schon
untergehen kein sparen lothar wieder ist
kein einfacher menschen die minister
sind auch nicht immer so die einfachsten
menschen und da kommt es auch zu
zerwürfnissen aber was bekannt ist ist
zum beispiel dass es auch verwerfungen
und wirklich misstöne gibt zwischen
verbänden und dem rkw chef also zwischen
den kassen ärzten relativ schweigsam saß
jetzt hier zum beispiel herr gassen der
chef der kassenärztlichen vereinigung
da da ist aber bekannt dass er zum
beispiel mit mit lothar wieler gar nicht
kann die als diese weiter hier heute
begegnet sind hat man sich aus zwei
meter entfernung kurz mit kopfnicken mal
begrüßt
geht man nicht miteinander lothar wieler
ist gilt aber trotzdem als relativ
sattelfest also dass er fest im sattel
sitzt auch aus einem einfachen grund man
kann nicht mittendrin das pferd
wechselnde oder auch nicht in writer weg
sind also lothar wieler wird gebraucht
er hat jetzt auch die erfahrung der weiß
wie ja auch vor die presse treten muss
der letzten kräftigen dämpfer gekriegt
was jetzt eben während der
pressekonferenz noch einmal merklich für
missstimmung gesorgt hat war als ein
kollege vom zdf nachgefragt hat der
neben mir saß und gefragt hat aber herr
wieder sie mussten doch wissen was sie
da auslösen und welchen rummste sieht
als wieder auslösen als wir wieder dann
sagte ich verfolge die nachrichten nicht
so intensiv wie sie glauben dass das
kann man auch so werden wir es mir doch
egal wer über mir über mich poltert also
wenn es mir doch wurscht wenn der
bundeskanzler sauer ist ich mache meine
arbeit ich bin behördenchef und damit
basta dabei hat er dann seine papiere
hin und her geschoben und man konnte
eben natürlich sehr stark ansehen wie
unangenehm in das ist vielleicht sollte
man auch einmal dazu sagen es geht
natürlich den journalisten und uns auch
nicht darum irgendwelche zwistigkeiten
zwischen zwei personen zu befördern
sondern es geht darum wieder einmal ein
kommunikationsproblem irgendwie
aufklären zu können denn wenn eine
expertenrat hingeht und eine empfehlung
ausspricht die die politiker dazu
bewegen zu sagen wir machen kontakt
beschränkungen ab dem 28 dezember und
dann eine halbe stunde vorher eine so
wichtige person wie herr wieder hingeht
oder das rk ii und sagt nein das muss
alles ab sofort gelten dann fragt man
sich natürlich wer hat recht und können
wir uns überhaupt auf die empfehlung der
politiker verlassen
na ja also es ist mehr als ein
kommunikationsproblem bei lothar wieler
musste natürlich wissen was er da
auslöst wenn lothar wieder wusste worauf
erstens was der expertenrat empfohlen da
jetzt ausgeführt dass das was er
empfohlen hat mit seinem lkw papier ja
gar nicht so weit davon entfernt sondern
eigentlich deckungsgleich da drauf passt
kann man so sehen muss man nicht so
sehen aber der zeitpunkt ist halt das
problem und zu diesem zeitpunkt hatten
sich bund und länder schon in
vorabsprachen für die gestrige
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auf ein
katalog auf 15 punkte geeinigt und als
dieser 15 punkte katalog intern vorlag
rasselte lothar wieler mit seinem papier
rhein und der minister selber lauterbach
war davon überrascht er ist in dieser
konferenz mit den ministerpräsidenten
reingegangen und er kannte das papier
nicht und das ist das was was nicht
passieren darf und lothar wieler hat
kürzlich mal im stern christus interview
gegeben und größeres stück wo sich auch
bitterlich darüber geklagt dass man auf
ihn ja immer nicht gehört hat und das
konnte jetzt durchaus wieder so gewertet
werden dass lothar wieder da der meinung
war leute vielleicht hörte er diesmal
auf mich ich möchte es zumindest vorher
mal wild mal gesagt haben und das kommt
überhaupt nicht gut an das ist nicht nur
ein kommunikationsproblem das ist auch
ein ego probleme sagt unser chefreporter
peter tiede er aus der
bundespressekonferenz uns zugeschaltet
peter der vielen herzlichen dank
geben nochmal auf die inhalte ein
philipp potthoff ist noch hier bei uns
im studio ansonsten eine sehr
zuversichtlicher karl lauterbach der
auch unterstützung bekam von andreas
gassen dem chef der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung man sei da im ziel die 30
millionen muster impfungen seien so gut
wie erreicht 28 sagte andreas gassen
sind bisher schon gebucht hat weitere 30
millionen sollen bis ende januar gebucht
werden und impfstoff gibt es auch genug
absolut das war eine erstaunlich
optimistische pressekonferenz zumindest
wenn man mal von den äußerungen von
herrn bieler absieht der wie gewohnt er
auf alarmismus gesetzt hat aber
ansonsten ist klar die booster kampagne
schreitet erfreulich schnell voran
schneller als man geglaubt wir haben die
angekündigten 30 millionen fast schon
erreicht und wollen nach danach nachdem
im neuen jahr weitere 30 millionen drauf
satteln und das heißt nach allem was man
weiß dass 30 millionen menschen einen
hervorragenden impfschutz haben auch
gegen schwere verläufe mit omikron
gleichzeitig fielen aber auch wie setzte
setzte die habe ich mir notiert
weihnachts das weihnachtsfest soll nicht
der funkel sein der das omikron feuer
entfacht dieser satz gesagt von l t chef
lothar wieler das lässt sie dann doch
wieder die alarmglocken läuten nicht die
weihnachtsglocken sondern leider
wirklich sehr an anlocken lothar wieler
betont immer dass er ja nur
wissenschaftler sei ich glaube bei
diesen mühsamen liebe voll formulierten
warnungen merkt man da versucht auch
jemand wirklich die öffentlichkeit zu
alarmieren zu warnen mit einer sehr
drastischen rhetorik also dass omikron
feuer entfachen das hört sich für mich
fast schon an wie das höllenfeuer ich
würde da eher auf die durchaus
nüchternere rhetorik von herrn gassen
oder von minister lauterbach setzen und
um noch einmal auf herrn wieder zu
sprechen bekommen seine aufgabe als
präsident des lka ist es ja eigentlich
zu garantieren dass deutschland
jederzeit über die notwendigen daten
verfügt um überhaupt zu wissen wie es um
die pandemie steht und wie befürchtet
hat lothar wieler verkündet dass wir uns
demnächst in den crooner blindflug
verabschieden wir werden in den
kommenden wochen nicht wissen wo wir
stehen weil wir es nach zwei jahren
pandemie nicht geschafft haben
systematisch zu testen sondern wir sind
immer davon abhängig wie viele leute
heute oder morgen ein crooner test
machen lassen und dann ihr ergebnis
bekommt das heißt sobald die labore
schließen sobald die leute in die
weihnachtsferien gehen weiß deutschland
nicht mehr wie es um corona im land
steht